so this clip is going viral cuz the
trainer on the showed The Biggest Loser
Jillian Michaels was doing an interview
and the woman was started to talk about
Liz oh and how she loves her music and
she loves what she stands for with the
body positivity movement Julianne
decided to take him home and say why are
we even focusing on her body how long
have I been saying this how long have
you been preaching from the rooftop we
should not be celebrating this if you
wanna be confident that's fine if you
like a I'm trying to get better but this
is me right now my current state but I
am eating healthier that's fine but
first a celebrate obesity and just like
that's her no it's not I know much food
[ __ ] to eat in the on discipline [ __ ]
[ __ ] to do to get to that level
addiction I was a food addiction yep but
she's gonna die okay you told me if
Julian Michael's not spot on and I love
celebrities like Liz o or Ashley grant
the biggest host of all time I love her
music yeah well a percent I don't know
anything about her I'm sure she's a cool
awesome check yeah and I love that
they're putting images out there that we
normally don't get to see of bodies that
we don't get to see being celebrated and
why are we celebrating her body why does
it matter that's what I'm saying like
why aren't we celebrating her music
because it isn't gonna be awesome if she
gets diabetes well I'm just being honest
like I love her music like my kid loves
her music but there's never a moment
where I'm like and I'm so glad that
she's overweight like why do we why do I
even care why is it we have a problem
with this hear about her weight a lot of
people did and why that's cuz they're
out of shape people did a lot of people
felt like she was fat shaming Liz Oh
which I don't think she was doing at all
she's just saying let's focus on her
music she's appealing we are all
beautiful worthy and equally desert I
also feel stronger that we love
ourselves enough to acknowledge that
there are seers helpers that come with
obesity heart disease diabetes cancer to
name only a few I would never wish these
on anyone and I would hope we prioritize
our health because we love ourselves on
our hungry Savior good for you John and
Michael hearts and yeah I'm not with
this movement like oh everything's
beautiful hold on if yeah if you like
fat cheeks or if you want to be a fat
that your prerogative but don't push the
narrative on us that this is the new and
it's okay to look like this be because
it's it's not healthy man it's not
healthy any facet we're not meant to be
that fat humans are not meant to be that
large and we're not sure body she's
overeating that's cause that says food
that sodas Saudis and my friends call it
Saudis I said she's not healthy I like
her music and listen it sometimes summer
post she's sexy but it's not it's not
healthy I think I think this is where
the Jamaicans are so professional
trainer yeah don't fat shame but at the
same time let's not celebrate the fact
that she's insanely overweight no here's
my thing I'm not gonna fat Shamer I
don't give a [ __ ] if she gets up 2,000
pounds but what I do care if you push
the narrative in my face and into the
younger generations face that it's okay
to be that fat right that's very that's
not a healthy message exact muzzle push
cigarettes
what's next cocaine yeah that's it as
healthy as this is this you know be
skills for people that may seem a loony
left wing or the loony woke or with the
loony whatever it is this is this
disease wackadoodles online and they're
just they're just noise but but people
were given Julie Michael [ __ ] you think
those people are all healthy and they
don't shape matter like you said again
it doesn't know the real boots on the
ground no one gives a [ __ ] [ __ ] and they
know she's right they know Jillian
Michaels is right everybody no no no
she's out of shape dude when she's 40
and she's looking in the mirror and the
doctors like hey man your cholesterol so
high like it was queued up for her
diabetes now you're by season number one
gotta start eating healthy diabetes make
you go blind you know did she like all
this doctors fat shaming me no no we
just we want you to live long you're
like your music yeah 100% that's the
truth but yeah this what she said to her
yeah Liz oh went onto IG live and she
made a small reference to it play
basically this is all right
my name is in your mouth so was my [ __ ]
[ __ ] enjoy the flavor yeah that's
that's a that's a good to go yeah
[ __ ] about Liz oh well I like your music
then do you know we give a [ __ ] about
our music I don't care either you fat
and fat and you should lose weight for
your eventual poor effort your because I
want you to be healthy and live longer
yeah how's that fat Shay it's not it's
it's the truth
you're you're telling the truth do you
want to have a talk with me if I was 300
pounds you lost a job dude you gotta
chill out dude
like I can't do the podcast but you're
so mean how could you do this to me I
get on the ground like wolf my my names
in your mouth but dicks in your mouth
we'd have to change broadcast to 10
because I'd be the number 1 and you'd be
the number zero cuz you're all fat
you're better than that dude right now
yeah yeah yeah yeah watch your tongue Oh
what's gonna happen what are you gonna
do use some of that boxing you've been
doing
[Laughter]